and the man Moses was very great in the
land of Egypt in the sight of Pharaoh's
servants and in the sight of the people
and Moses said shall we have a pharaoh
who did not know Joseph
but loved Joseph and now what do we have
another Jew who the Egyptians adore
it's just ironic right right Joseph and
now Moses
that that language is used of Joseph as
well isn't it yeah let's see with regard
to the people no I don't think so but
they knew he saved their lives so but in
this case did they I don't know if they
adored him at least it says Joseph No
Moses they say he was great okay
so both of them were great in this
question for sure Joseph they love
that's for sure where are you
emotionally I'm just curious about this
in like are you when you're reading this
or you're reading this in eager
anticipation of the Pharaoh being
punished are you reading this in
trepidation and because I remember it
was just me it's more trepidation it's
like I think because I probably identify
with the Pharaoh you do well yeah you
think about losing a child yeah just
about the consequences of your own
stupidity it's like are you feeling are
you feeling Vindicated right like
vengeful that you're hoping that the
Pharaoh is going to get his are you
feeling remorse in empathy for what's
coming what is your emotional because I
remember I used to read in like high
school history when you'd read like
World War one and World War II it's like
you have that sense of being it's
constant like I really hope that America
wins right like you're you have this
emotional positioning in relation to
reading history even if you know the
outcome and I'm just curious but in this
like there's this this growing looming
threat as if God is saying this is don't
know if you don't listen this is where
we're going he's not telling you where
we're going yet it's almost like a very
it's like in a movie right you can feel
the music like coming up and you can
feel the threat and you know like please
let it stop before it reaches that point
you don't even know where it's going and
then once it gets there I I don't think
is it possible to not feel sad for the
Egyptians and to not feel sympathy and
to not wish that the Pharaoh had broken
before and it's like you get there and
you're like
Dennis how about you
uh I hope Pharaoh gets his yeah I I
admit I knew I can count on him what
about the Egyptians I was like that's
why I was just waiting I was like is
that a good sign or a bad stuff
he's clearly the villain and yes exactly
I want villains to get punished I don't
know I I'm but do you want the villains
to learn before they have to pay the
ultimate price that's such a Christian
question I know that's why that's why
I don't get the damage they learned
before they die I I want them to die
yeah because I I'm more concerned with
good people I don't want good people to
suffer so so whether Pharaoh learns or
Knob is between pharaoh and Pharaoh but
between pharaoh and me he has to be
punished but the great lesson which is
of course unlearned like most great
lessons is people people do really like
tyrants I there's no way around that
one of you mentioned this and I didn't
so I didn't bother commenting on it but
polls in in Russia prior to uh to
Ukraine uh showed the increasing
proportions of of the Russian people
adore Stalin yeah well that's the same
thing that happens to the Israelites
they complained to Moses because they
want a monarch no they want to go back
to Egypt Okay
order and the greatness of Russia I know
Russians now also one might
admire the order there's always order
under retirement
that's okay
but they still are happy when the Tyrant
there's also some question about the
veracity of polling under Stalin
Nostalgia for but some of that's
ignorance too you know they look back
and they just see the greatness so to
speak right but it's willful ignorance
yeah I know but don't you think in this
text it is clear it's either like in the
second it's clear that there is this
it's trying to show us that the people
of Egypt now find these Israelites find
favor in their sight they're giving them
jewels and things for them to leave and
they had they see Moses as being very
powerful in this site and then in the
text itself it switches right away to
saying now all the firstborn will die
and he says of the Pharaoh and then he
says to the woman behind the mill
and so it's like right in the text a few
verses from each other you see that
people have compassion for the
Israelites and then it says no but their
children are going to die too that's why
I feel like they're
sense in which we're meant to have
compassion even for the Egyptians
takeoff and how many Germans
were grateful for the order that Hitler
seemed to bring and then they suddenly
realized
chaos pretend not to defend the Germans
but it is fair to say that Hitler didn't
get a majority of the vote the Nazis
didn't get a majority vote but between
the Communists and the Nazis they did
get a majority the The Tyranny parties
did did went out I'm with you
yeah yeah thank you
daily that Putin monkey has come up I
really do pray your point of willful
blindness I mean that holds both ways
like you have polling now about
communism right you have pulled I think
this has to do with with like we a
generational remove from the horrors of
both Stalin and what happened in
communism right so right it is both
directions you mean both willful and and
just normal is that what you're saying I
mean that it's not just that people look
back fondly on tyrants people look back
on me and communism that were they were
removed from a certain distance of it so
the willful blindness and the ignorance
isn't listen the the number of Americans
and and and English who gave Stalin the
bomb
uh the the flirtation with tyranny on
the part of western intellectuals is
among the most depressing facts of the
20th century the Eastern European
Eastern Europeans have experienced they
don't that's right but I mean what like
when we're polling today
yeah in the west if you pull down
communism right and likewise with with
tyranny like if you know if Stalin's do
what percentage of Harvard seniors do
you think could identify Pol Pot
like I would say five percent
yeah I think you're probably being
optimistic on that okay I mean when I
taught about the gulag catastrophes or
the catastrophes
never heard of any of that that's really
any of them today have heard of salt and
Vincent oh sir oh oh that's a given but
Paul plump you know what the great Mass
murderers he killed a quarter of his own
people by the way these tyrants killed
Hitler is the only of of the tyrants
that didn't mostly Slaughter his own
people
Paul putt killed cambodians Mao killed
Chinese
Stalin killed Russians it's it and they
and they're still held in esteem how
about Mussolini well he wasn't a mass
murderer he's not in their category he
was a tyrant but he's not in their
category
Italians don't make that type yeah the
Italians make lousy tyrants yeah